Hallo, lass ein Licht an, Hüte ist rekonstruiert,
ausgewählt durch einfachen deutschen Besuch, Heidemann aus
Namibia, auf Tyvek, verliebt in das Institut,
auf via Matta und Ganses Team, hier von
Unzen, englisches Annalee-Roulette, Sir,
Weg zu Vivica, Dion, geh, Süße, auf
Vanessa, okay, jetzt auf DS, XD-Kommunikation, höchste
Konzentration  Xuan VIN salam ala
deutsch sprechen auf jung gehen Idee zuweisen, aber
Candice Tour führt ihn landen auf
Ärsche auf Sie können ich bin Sonya Sie kennen die
jüngere Seite Beweise zu Themen bei
Cyclins Gericht berühren auf Reha X 1 doppeltes
argentinisches D in Funktionsverbot  auf VMAs
Nevada Alyssa Fans buh ba D Bonuswechsel
Diese alte Hauptstadt von Nemedia ist einfach superg DeYoung Kogan Stones
Berater Boudicca 60 deistische Befürworter hielten
Ja, Süße VIN nahm seinen englischen
Lexia Hawk über Spiegel Spiegel
Lösungsabschnitt auf Schiffen in hundert Meter Oh
als sein  na Jie Braut Gilligan raste in
die Augen Aaron V, der das Gepäck
über uns in einer natalen Aura in einem Netz wechselt, hier
können Sie
Gonca über Aden über Ham Intuitio durcheinander bringen
n Eva Angst vor Hunderttausend und
Warner in Vintage jünger war in Viet
vivica
ja tatsächlich Xia vom Parlament für
Namibia als De Bunda Stop in Dodge,
also ist Suzanne hier im Hinterland
ja Parlamentsgarten Medientrockenstart
oder der I Netzschuss hua ist  getan Dia
Reverend Hamilton Pegula jemals ein ADEA-
Permanent erwähnte die Sunnah-Panik
Ich würde Libyen und Alejandra Diaz es und
lieber Chef O Ciock Otaku Amanda macht eine
Petition an Unterschieden und Energie zu
Phänomenen Sicher
Munna Bhai ist sein Github die Hinton-Hammer-
Idee Hendrick  Mit Jungen sind sie weniger
Phonin, die
im Zoo Dhin Dhin herumlungern, als ihre
Tante das Parlament der Wohnung de
nuit Republik Namibia ist, nicht sie, nicht sie
per Telefon nach Afrika
Eine kostenlose Cavell-Periode über
Solargase unter dem Nationalmuseum hier kann man
ooh bang Digga Schwester Namibia
slannen, das ist Abnahme, Sir - ist das
Goethe-Institut, ja  kann manwich Lennon
jünger war in Viet Vanessa ja in Schulden,
aber der Betrag in Kedah para totora
ist ein e Malika Schwarz ein Bundestelefon
gewonnen hat so laut ja Anzug Afrikaner
ist Regime Apartheidsystem, wenn ein Medien-
und Telefon fünfzig Provinzen
Südafrika hat  Sky Service in Joburg
Johannesburg hatte sogar Metapod gab zu, dass
Watsa ein tödlicher Schnitt ein Hockeyspiel ist,
dass die Tora das seltsame Wort Emerson ist
und ein Ereignis, das auf dem Virgania-Zug gesündigt hat
, in diesem beim Kochen markiert ist, gab
es hier einen auf Beinen leidenden jüngeren Vasque-
Esser von ihnen  hier und dann ist Gott ein
Schneider zu bemerken, wenn er Akitas
Mängel fliegt gewinnt ein Diss
fliegt, als sein nicht realisierter der Kühlschrank hier
Filmographie Awards bargeldlos Adrian Monk
auf diesem Out Mart Wodka kostet hier
Quebrada K gebohrt Mann kann Vanina's o
Capanna
getan mit meinem Diamant-Asset  die wie
verblendet den Klan-Ägypter auf
Essenz ánotá durch den Hinton Common begleiten und
Frisch's Reihe blinkt auf einem Sarg auf
Staub2 Häusern, die in Ashmac unterstützen, siehe siehe  ein
Laker und sein Name bedeutet Ma'am,
wir untersuchen Vanessa auf der Karte -
ja, besucht in
wir sind auch Anleitungsvideos Spione Mann,
lass uns jetzt treffen, um es aufzuregen,
ist Mahesh, neuer Ferrari, dieser ist offener,
albern, jodiert,
schlägt nicht auf
den Knöchel  war noch nicht
so, wir sind noch nicht gesündigt hiermit Pen
Dukkha Auslandsprojekt, wie ein A aus
einem Empowerment-Trick war eine andere Ära
Hand Abbott Martin und Recycling aus der
Alt-Erwachsenenklasse in Vandana Katie
Restauratorin okay, wenn Sie markieren können, ich weiß,
okay hatte  jüngere Phi C und V es ging um
die genaue Version, aber siehe bei Katie Ich
war ein seltsames Glas recycelt MC Darrows
Que Diga Master gibt Strauss ab und ich
werde unter HMDA hier raustelefonieren und
hier ungefähr Babys
ist der Independence Avenue nambian Flip
- ist  Just do Park in Namibia
, das ist auf der Knöchelstraße erfunden
tipo Street macht ist ein neuer Park auf TN-
Kurven-Syndrom
hallo Lee verwandt das ist 102 Deutsche
VIN rede später vazhi Felder
freispricht abhava - tut verdampfen und beschäftigt und dann
a  erbärmliches Opfer für Fahnenflucht al Anton
Entscheidung beginne mit der Installation von TN sind üblich
am Ofen im Oktober. Wir sterben. Das Leben
ist MIT
Deutscher Sprachtipp für
dich heute also hat khadi im heutigen Video gleich
zu Beginn
gesagt, dass sie Jägervagen-
Mythos sind, die sich gut einführen lassen, also
schauen wir uns das Wort Jägervagen an, das ist
ein erstaunliches Wort, ich benutze dieses Wort gerne
auf Deutsch, aber manchmal übersetze ich es
kann ein bisschen knifflig sein, also
bedeutet die wortwörtliche Übersetzung von „hunter vagues“ wörtlich „unterwegs“ und daher wird
es oft ins Englische übersetzt als
„enroute“ oder „on the way“, aber
in diesem Fall ist die Art und Weise, wie die Kata es verwendet hat,
ein bisschen kniffliger, weil es wirklich so ist
bedeutet einfach so etwas wie draußen oder vielleicht unterwegs
, aber draußen funktioniert nicht
wirklich, weil Hunter Vages dieses
Gefühl von stiller Bewegung hat, es hat
Bewegung dazu und draußen nicht rea  Ich
habe Bewegung und unterwegs ist
Bewegung, aber es ist eine sorglose Bewegung,
du bist einfach nett, du bist unterwegs,
du gehst, wohin du willst, und
Hunter Biggs hat nicht wirklich dieses
Gefühl, es ist ein bisschen still
geplanter und strukturierter, so dass es
nicht immer eine perfekte Übersetzung für ein
Wort gibt, und ich denke, das ist heute mein Tipp,
dass es manchmal keine
perfekte Übersetzung für ein
deutsches Wort in Ihre Muttersprache oder
ins Englische geben wird, also seien Sie einfach nett
zu lernen und zu verstehen und zu
fühlen was unter vagues auf
deutsch ist und nicht zu versuchen zu fühlen was es in
deiner muttersprache ist das war dein schneller
deutscher sprachtipp für heute ich wünsche dir
alles gute beim deutsch lernen bis zum nächsten
mal auf  wiedersehen